earlier in the show you heard wayne  newton talking about growing up  basically here in las vegas he came here  though with his brother when he was just  15. he says his parents as brother act  as a chaperone and it turns out show  business just was not for him take a  listen show business didn't mean  anything to help me in fact he kind of  hated it so in 1970 he quit  and he quit in the middle of the night  we were doing a sean denver colorado  and uh  i get a call about eight o'clock in the  morning from my drummer  and he said uh jerry left  and i said what  jerry left  he said he's had enough of this so  i was appearing at the frontier in those  days here  and  they withheld  the flowers for the dressing room  until my first show was over because  they didn't think that i could do a show  without my brother being there  and  so i've gone through all those kinds of  nebson turns  to realize that  this is the greatest city in the world